the puppies are they yeah that's so
twisted that's messed up I case you mix
that with mine again some of you so may
be fine with this free why don't you get
on with it then for what it's worth I'll
show you how the um I'll shame that feel
me oh you know to everybody sorry it's
like breaking the fourth wall that work
I'm going to UM I'm going to show you
how these results come about right and
then we'll have a look at the sheets if
you tell me if there's something
question underneath what exercise number
is it it's 15.6 if there's any under
there which really are all logged under
this kind of question that you
particular have it go out okay all right
so yeah um do you never need to prove it
yeah number one side number two if you
don't know how to prove it I think some
of the tricky questions later on will
cause you trouble because you don't
understand how it works so if we throw
your curb or you'd be like this doesn't
fit into my you know my normal questions
right you've really got to understand
the real thing to be able to do the
question does that make sense I don't
think I've ever seen a question but said
prove the results for someone but there
are some questions and they they use
that tone of voice as well but there are
some questions when you look at it and
if you don't understand how to prove it
you just kind of scratch it him okay
some prior it's what are we talking
about if you take a quadratic
any quadratic right um we should be able
to define its roots as alpha beta now
you might be saying wait hold on a
second we we just looked because what do
you say let's keep going try to start
against ivory oh I am what the hell's
your Excuse let's start again shall we
I'm quadratic
this is so making to the air right you
know why she's just for them you're
getting parts of it haha when it could
we looked at me hello my son lo in good
hands and like cuts you know your
techniques are here what would you call
that the Evan hand chili video one what
do you think so I just like to take it
down and actually realized what a little
IDK that's right try it with my registry
that video she just start against mr.
boss he's always on a separate wrongful
group sure okay yeah we should we I
should make the I can I should name the
child in pain to do such a good
education groups okay take a deep breath
we were just haha
okay this is like when I cut I can
imagine when you got like a really
serious movie right and they're all the
axes trying to do the take and there's
just something funny in the background
it okay guys slow down slow down sorry
gather every month ago doesn't give me
like I'm even gonna I mean we're gonna
write it down that's true the deep
breath tree doesn't work haha I just
kicking leave the room and then i can
actually started yeah it's my story is
funny what are your two like 20 minutes
in solidarity it's gonna be the assembly
planet